oh oh wow
most of the time at the end of the
relationship really because uh he Fade
Out really you know yeah I had I had a
long-term relationship that was five
years long
um and I felt like I was pretty lonely
in that relationship but it's because
you wake up every day knowing that
you're incompatible with someone so I
think like that in itself can be its own
psychological torture and I think that
has something to do with a reason why a
lot of marriages you know like fail or
are sexless and like guys are just at
times just going to church to stay
married just so they don't leave their
wife or cheat on their wife so yeah the
loneliest I felt was outside of was
outside a relationship but that's
because I built my relationship like
with my son and all that kind of stuff
so when I wrote when I wrote that off I
was like damn yeah I think a really
important thing here for guys because
because again you know the the the sort
of maybe the expected answer is like oh
I was really lonely I was in this
particular relationship but I was really
lonely because but but actually that
wasn't the case for me most of the time
I've been in relationships you know I'm
not not loneliest hasn't been my main
issue my most lonely was probably when I
was about 18 19 first went to University
really really hard to say it didn't
really socialize found it really hard to
make friends had had a few friends
didn't have girlfriend and I was I felt
really really away from family felt
really really alone and and that was a
really difficult time for me
um and then then I I got a girlfriend
and then after that I broke up with her
and then I was back into the abyss and
feeling really really lonely then again
but I think a key a key Point here is
yes the relationships with the women but
the key thing for guys really is
relationships is is friendships with
other men having a group of friends
around you because because I've never
like and now I'm in a very fortunate
position Edition because I've got
friends I've got people I've known for
many many years and you know I had a
breakup a year or so ago which was which
was really tough but I've never felt
that degree of loneliness because I've
always known those people were there and
I think that's the key but you know
what's happening to men nowadays I can
feel when it comes to know this is it a
lot of them are getting into like gaming
and so all they're doing they're
interacting on their headphones on their
headsets with people and these are their
quote-unquote Bros yeah yeah
sorry so good does hookup culture leave
people lonely yeah of course it does
of course I I I think hook up culture
leaves you wanting
to keep if you what if you keep wanting
to do it again I've had sex with this
person I want to have sex with that
person I want to ask why is is there a
hole somewhere in you that needs that
needs to be filled so like I get it we
live in the time of hookup culture I get
it I just think um the interactions
between men and women now in these days
and times I I just don't think we're
being honest with ourselves although
although you're saying that but but I
mean I've read statistics that that
would indicate that there is hip-hop
culture going on there but it it's for
the it's rather for us to like fear yeah
there's a lot of guys there's a lot of
dudes who aren't benefiting from that
hookup culture at all you know yeah but
for for women
um that's the new rate of Passage yeah
yeah and becoming like going from a girl
and becoming a woman there's like that
whole phase that's in between and
sometimes it follows you like all the
way into Womanhood of course but I think
that's like really sad and truly a
detriment and there's other Rites of
Passage that women could have had that I
think would would have left them less
lonely you know things like you know
having a sweet 16 uh having
um an engagement shower a bridal shower
having a wedding and things like that
but now it's like you know why don't you
just explore this new power and ability
to swipe on your phone I I just don't
think that it makes any kind of sense
yes I'll say I'll say one thing that I
think I think has changed in my
observation from back in the day and it
seems it seems like there's this sort of
default thing now for women and maybe
for men as well but for women of just
it's like being hot is the only
and I don't I don't think that was the
case years ago back in the 90s I mean I
don't know whether you can attest to
this but um it seemed it seemed like you
know there were some girls who were oh
she's she's more of a bookish kind of
intellectual or there's another one and
she wants to know yeah be an artist and
now it seems like and I'm not saying for
everybody because obviously you can't
generalize but it does seem like the
currency now is she you know am I hot
how many followers have I got on
Instagram it's that seems to be the main
stuff it's like a man it's like a
factory yeah yeah you're just building
these things off of factories is that
mannequins yeah and so many girls as
well develop that same sort of look uh
yeah you know the botox you know the
lips with the filler they're just just
that same kind of look so sad because
some are so pretty before too yeah and
they like ruined their natural beauty
yeah well if I can give you an example
for example now back in the day is a
girl when she got like uh finished the
College of God deguria the university
they used to be asked for a car now they
have to have you know the boobs done
maybe yeah some you know the nose down
if it's not it's not good right is again
in a world where everything is based on
a picture yeah yes if you don't look
good in the picture you know you won't
get anything right and that's most of
the time
um and this is the reality I mean back
in the days uh personality is important
there is a minority of people like you
know to chat especially in their field
you know I grew up with painters when I
was a teenager in Rome was Arnold all
about the contemporary artists so even
if I didn't want in any College of Art
if I talk with somebody in this sector
um I kind of have a conversation and
kind of attract them on the point of
view but then again if they're very
young in a way they got Central Standard
to say oh yeah but I got to be look like
that no because they still influenced
about you know the application that's
their culture that's the way they grow
up well it's automatic like we're kind
of preyed upon so this is the crazy
thing I did a video on this once about
how like social media Engineers you as
women to it can engineer you into an
eating disorder like this is this is
actually like tested by Facebook they
did private research thanks guys thanks
for not making that public research at
the time but um okay so from my
experience and then and then I'll bring
in like the the psychological
programming so I signed up for Instagram
I didn't have an Instagram for a very
long time I think I signed up sometime
in my early 20s and all I put was like
my age so early 20s I'm a female and
then I guess it knew that I was in the
United States as well immediately my
entire full page is full of like these
fitness models and by the way like the
science doesn't even match that because
a lot of these fitness models don't have
enough fat on their body to conceive
life okay so it's like it's a subjective
definition of Health but um so like when
it came to like teen girls and that was
specifically who Facebook studied uh
that you they would just like get
flooded with you these images and you uh
everyone kind of responds to extreme
content like what's going to get you to
click and so you can go from a salad
into learning how to starve yourself as
a woman so our phones like make us hate
our bodies and that's like something
that I've gone through multiple times
um I guess with like I don't know by
bias for Via dysmorphia
um with my husband I've had these
conversations because I I was overweight
almost obese I lost 45 pounds but your
body just yeah yeah you don't look like
you're obese your girl can eat all right
yeah
well almost almost it was my BMI was
29.9 so I lost uh 45 pounds and my body
changed a lot and then I kept working
out I actually like ran my breasts off
it's like these things are just very
stressful and they weigh in on a woman
and that's why women hi you need to be
in a relationship with a man so that way
when your body changes not because you
decided to be lizzo about it but when
your body changes he can look at you and
say like no no you're still beautiful
like yeah you ran your breast all off
like that's fine you're still high you
still got the Buns you look good right I
think we really need that reinforcement
from men but not like just any guy out
there it's better to have that
reinforcement in a in a long-term
committed relationship because you're
gonna get insecure as a woman it's gonna
happen yeah that's very true
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible